[MUSIC PLAYING]
SMITHA HANEEF: We want you to
feel like you're in a place
that you would refer to
as a home away from home,
and eventually
becomes your home.
MICHAEL GATTIS: Our
mission is to tie
into what is going
on here at Princeton,
and that's education.
And we have that gift, to be
able to do that through food.
Students that haven't
tried something can try it,
and it's opening up
their world as well.
SMITHA HANEEF: Right now
for the Class of 2020,
it's the largest percentage
of diverse student
body we have seen in the
history of Princeton.
So it's a beautiful confluence
of such a wide range
of diverse communities
coming together.
And through food, we are able
to not only educate and nourish
them, but also inform them
about cultural sensitivities,
about diverse ethnic
cuisine types.
We celebrate five heritage
months across campus.
And student groups
engage with us
in designing menus and events.
During the Native
American Heritage Month,
one of our students,
Emery, came to us
and partnered with
our team members.
In fact, he is leaving
a legacy for Princeton
in educating about Native
American heritage through food
and through food culture.
EMERY REAL BIRD: One
of our main events
was the Night of Native Foods.
And basically it was a
time to highlight food that
originated from the Americas.
So you're thinking of
corn, beans, tomatoes.
And we also look to
Native suppliers.
So there was actual wild
rice, not cultivated
in the large fields.
So there are recipes that are
derived from foods that people
who are American Indian, but
of a certain tribal group, that
is what they would eat.
MAYEE CHEN: Asian
Pacific Heritage Month
is a month long of
different events
celebrating all
aspects of the culture,
for Asian and Pacific Islanders.
We have Whitman having
a Hawaiian theme,
Wilson having a Chinese
theme, and Rocky
having an Indian theme.
Oftentimes it's like we get our
plates of food, we sit down,
and the food itself is a very
common ground for discussion.
It'll be like oh,
this is really good,
and oh, I've never
tried this before.
The different types
of cuisines definitely
bring about a sense
of community in that.
CHAD ROVNER: When I
started working here,
I noticed that every
dining hall really
didn't have much to
offer in Indian food.
And I started seeing
the clientele really
started to change.
And there was a lot of
students from India.
And a lot of them
would talk to me
and were a little
homesick for the food.
They would send me
emails with dishes
they wanted me to start making.
I would look into it, I would
start practicing making it.
I really want them to have
the experience of what
Indian food really would be.
BINITA GUPTA: I feel the food
is really authentic, especially
when they do vegetables.
Like the lentil curry,
for example today,
was something that my
mom could have made.
Honestly if you gave me my
mom's dish and this dish,
I might not have been able
to tell the difference.
Anytime there's Indian food,
I'll take a picture and text it
to them and be like look, this
is what I'm having for today.
And it makes them really
happy, because sometimes they
worry about me
being here and not
adjusting or being uncomfortable
with the food choices.
But whenever
there's Indian food,
they know that I feel at home
and I feel really welcome here.
And I like learning
about other cultures too.
And I really hope
that other people
learn about Indian culture
through the dining hall food
too.
SMITHA HANEEF: I am
an immigrant myself.
I'm a naturalized citizen.
I've lived in Boston,
Birmingham, Alabama, Mountain
View, California.
And living in these places has
taught me some really powerful
lessons.
Being a chef myself, I have
learned American culture
through the cuisines.
RICK PIANCONE: I grew up in
a little Italian specialty
shop and bakery that my parents
had in Bradley Beach, New
Jersey, making
mozzarella as a child,
learning how to bake bread.
Last year we met with
the Italian table,
and we asked them
if they would like
to see a demonstration
of fresh mozzarella being
made in the evening.
So we had about 10
students in the kitchen.
And we got a real wow out of it.
We say, hey, this is something
we can add to the menu.
We try to hear their
home type foods, what's
really close to their heart.
And it's so good to
hear areas of food
that I'm not familiar with of
other regions, other countries.
All the chefs here
in the operation
are really trying to learn
these different ethnic dishes.
We're never going to make it
100% like Mom or Grandma did,
but we try to get it
as close as possible.
MICHAEL GATTIS: When we prepare
food, we share a piece of us
with the person who's eating it.
And that's where the
passion comes from.
When a student gets to do
that from what they brought
from home to share with their
fellows, a piece of them
and their heritage, that's
the community that we're
trying to build here
at Princeton and just
captures everything
we're all about.